para su primer mitin desde la elección
presidencial donald trump eligió a yo ya
aquí para sus partidarios la derrota fue
particularmente difícil de tragar job
aiden quedó primero en este estado era
la primera vez para un candidato
demócrata desde 1992 pero el presidente
en ejercicio sigue siendo fuerte
continúa martillando sin pruebas que la
elección fue a mañana
si perdiera sería un perdedor muy amable
si perdiera diría he perdido e iría
florida y me lo tomaría con calma y
daría la vuelta y diría que he hecho muy
buen trabajo pero nunca puedes aceptar
cuando roban y manipulan
[Música]
los demócratas intentaron robar la
presidencia y lo están haciendo muy bien
alguna vez te has dado cuenta de las
noticias falsas
más de un mes después de las elecciones
georgia sigue en el centro de la batalla
electoral pero esta vez para el senado
aquí ningún candidato de la cámara alta-
obtuvo el 3 de noviembre una mayoría
suficiente para ser elegido otra
votación crucial tendrá lugar el 5 de
enero si sus dos candidatos fracasan los
republicanos perderán la mayoría del
senado entonces donald trump busca
movilizar a sus votantes a todo precio
los votantes de georgia determinaron que
partido dirige cada comité redacta cada
legislación controla cada dólar de los
contribuyentes
si los candidatos david verdú y que el
hilo flores ganan los republicanos
permanecerán en la mayoría con 52
escaños frente a 48 demócratas esto
haría difícil la presidencia para joe
biden pero si los demócratas ganan será
un 50-50 en ese caso la vicepresidenta
kamala harris tendrá el voto decisorio